son son son son son son Thanos is back
ladies and gents boys and girls Thanos
has returned to Marvel Comics okay so
this picks up with this girl who
literally looks like death because I
think she's mistress death and we'll
talk about why here in a minute but this
girl has just kind of this life right
where she initially kind of Muses about
some podcast she watches called the love
of my life whatever it doesn't really
matter what matters is that while this
chick works at a pharmacy along with her
co-workers right off the bat we know
that she's just kind of isolated she's
alone she does her own thing but the way
she looks right like she looks like some
kind of goth girl that like loves the
idea of death but doesn't actually want
to die and so in the midst of that
Thanos makes his way to earth now we
only see the tail end of his ship but
Thanos starts making his way towards
Earth now there comes a point when this
woman and this is where like the mystery
kicks off like that as she's ringing up
this older woman this older woman looks
at her and is like oh my God you're my
Marie right and like Thanos appears in
Earth's orbit now at that point things
go sideways like immediately because
this girl says her name is Roberta
Marshall but this older woman is just
fixated on the idea that she's actually
a girl named Marie now earlier in the
comic book you do see this woman go to a
grave site that belongs to a woman named
Marie who basically died at 21 years old
the ages kind of match up but again this
is why I make the argument I think this
woman is mistress death and the reason
why is because for those of you guys who
don't know in Marvel Comics in what is
it genus Vel Captain Marvel issue number
five mistress death retired at the end
of that comic she retired she was like
I'm done I don't want to be mistress
death anymore like I'm tired of doing
that job presumably just kind of go off
and live a life for herself what better
way to do that than to just like travel
to earth take over the body of a
21-year-old girl who basically died now
the question you're probably asking is
wouldn't someone notice right we'll talk
about that here in a second but what
goes on is things go sideways so quick
because Thanos immediately launches an
attack against Earth and basically
carves out this entire city like carves
out the whole place now what's so crazy
is that this Girl Rebecca is just like
all right come on drive like get
somewhere safe and This Woman's like I
won't leave you again right her response
is please just go your name it's
Christine right like I'll find you okay
but right now you have to live and So
Christine just drives way right does
exactly as she's instructed but then a
call for help comes from inside the
pharmacy Roberta gets inside there and
then finds one of her co-workers who's
just like pinned down by a machine now
Roberta is able to help this guy get
free but as we all know no good deed
goes unpunished this guy just bails
right he just takes off running and so
like when some debris falls down on her
this guy just leaves her there right he
just leaves her there in veils and so at
that point it seems to kind of I
wouldn't say work out in her favor
though but the fact that she didn't
leave at the same time he did basically
makes sense because seemingly he's
destroyed as like he makes his way out
because whatever is going on here like a
giant laser is cutting around this
entire city ultimately it's pulled out
of the ground and because the
International Space Station is chiming
in on what they see we end up finding
out this is Fresno California now is it
weird that thing would choose to attack
Fresno kind of but not really because
way back in the day in Marvel Comics he
just like attacked a car that was
driving through the mve desert because
he was afraid the car may have seen his
ship kind of a fun fact here inside the
car was a husband a wife and a daughter
the wife died the husband went on to
become draxx the destroyer and the
daughter went on to become moon dragon
Heather and Arthur duglas is exactly
what their names were so it's not to say
that like it's weird that Thanos would
attack Fresno I think it's kind of funny
right because what reason would anybody
have to go to Fresno in the first place
but the other reason why I say that I
think this girl is mistress death is
because she kind of Muses about this
idea that like she's going to die and
she in essence tells us she has no one
she's got no brothers she's got no
mother no father no kids no nothing so
if mistress death were going to reappear
on Earth by taking over the body of
somebody else why not pick a girl that
no one knows about right that has no one
who knows her right who's just kind of a
loner out there doing her own thing
quite literally an island unto herself
now the other question has to be asked
here is if this is mistress death why
doesn't she just stop Thanos we'll
figure that out here in a second but as
Thanos is watching this whole thing and
making his way to Earth seemingly he
picks up on this idea of this woman
saying I will die alone and just kind of
like repeating it and then he just
addresses the place directly right hear
me Fresno there is one among you whom I
seek the rest are half there will be a
calling until I find her and so as
Roberta starts to make her way back up
she's met by this kind of like broadcast
within the store right attention could
Roberta Marshall please come to the
front of the store thank you Miss
Marshall we don't mean you any harm when
she gets to the front she meets the new
Illuminati now here's the thing right
here's the thing some familiar faces
here Iron Man Reed Richards doctor
strange it's cool to see Emma Frost here
but Adam ver year the blue Marvel is
officially part of the team have you
guys been noticing they're raising his
profile he's in everything now this is
why I say I firmly believe that Adam B
the blue Marvel is in the Marvels I
haven't seen the movie I have no clue if
that's true but I feel like he is in
some capacity because they're raising
his profile he's in everything also
Christopher cwell and alng are like me
they love blue Marvel so you see them
putting him in everything but you get
this kind of roll call right now for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
Amar with how this team functions within
Marvel Comics the idea of it having a
roster that changes was not actually a
thing until Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers when Brian Michael
Bendis originally made the team in the
one-hot comic as part of Civil War you
had Reed Richards Doctor Strange Iron
Man blackbolt of the Inhumans which
makes no sense because he sucks black
panther neyar the Submariner and Charles
Xavier of the X-Men and that was
basically it it wasn't until you got to
uh Avengers The New Avengers that you
find out that Captain America was at one
point part of the team but because he
refused to go along with destroying
alternate worlds during the incursions
that Tony Stark ordered Doctor Strange
to wipe his mind and they threw him out
of the Illuminati so again the idea of
it having a shifting roster you don't
see it often but the fact that it's
shifted up here kind of makes sense
given the fact that like Charles Xavier
is sitting on ccoa during the fall of X
protecting the island and basically
ignoring everything else it makes sense
why he wouldn't be here blackbolt
wouldn't be here because the Illuminati
realized he sucked and black panther is
off doing his own thing in wakanda so it
makes perfect sense that you would have
like kind of a new roster but you get
this sort of a roll call right I mean
most of you guys know Reed Richard you
know Iron Man blue Marvel is kind of a
Superman allegory but not really the guy
is ridiculously op is really all you
need to know like he one shot ultimate
Hulk it was amazing when he did that do
you guys remember that in the like when
you met him in the Ultimate Universe and
Hulk's like I'm the strongest one there
is and blue Marvel like to paraphrase
here is something to the effect of like
I would beg to differ and just like
uppercuts the guy and takes him out in
one hit it was amazing like it was he
just KO him in one punch it was awesome
like it was just one of the coolest
moments in the history of Marvel Comics
I think we have a video about that
actually we'll have to double check if
we do have a video for you'll find it at
the end of this video If we don't we'll
make one but one of the things that Emma
Frost says is presumably as this
conversation had transpired with regards
to the Illuminati talking about why
Thanos is coming after this girl in the
first place the response of Emma is
loose threats perhaps but I'm sensing
she still has no grasp of the larger
truth the psychic block is still intact
possibly mistress death put a mental
block in her own mind so she doesn't
know who she is it's not uncommon it
happens in Marvel Comics relatively
frequently more often than you would
think actually now Adam Brasher does
kind of continue to make his case right
you know like I'm also a living
anti-matter reactor you know but the
fact remains here that as the group is
leaving the question that's asked here
by Roberta is why me right when Iron Man
says there's a very very bad individual
who's very interested in you when she
ask why me the response is it's
complicated and she says like I don't
understand I'm nobody and now the
Avengers are here and they're kind of
like well we're not really the Avengers
we're kind of an off thee books team
right like they're the Illuminati right
but the issue here is when they ask like
what's the next step right what do we do
the response of Iron Man is like it's
Thanos man right like it's literally
Thanos the Mad Titan has come here to
Earth in order to attack it and remove
Fresno California for reasons that makes
sense to nobody but himself and he's
going after this particular girl right
the Mad Titan immune to death right the
guy was banned from the realm of
mistress death presumably he still is
this guy cannot be killed he'll always
come back the best thing we can possibly
do is survive right this is the question
that I'm asking you guys who are
watching this video right now do you
think Adam Brasher the blue Marvel is
going to fight Thanos and if he does do
you think he can hold his own or do you
think he'll get crushed either way I'm
excited to see it Christopher canwell
please make it happen with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace